we're simply bridging the gap and
facilitating the scheduling uh for the
individuals in order to connect you know
whereas before you couldn't just reach
out to one of these individuals and be
like hey man you would you like to game
uh that that that's something that
doesn't happen uh whereas we give them
the ability to do that um now they can
stream if they would like on twitch or
facebook or whatever platform youtube
that they want but it's not a
requirement
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about celebrities and fans
meet carl padilla owner and ceo of celeb
gap
hall created celeb gap as a way to
bridge the gap between celebrities and
their biggest fans on this platform carl
has created a way to be able to send an
amazing gift or give yourself a unique
moment with a celeb of their choice
from actors and musicians to reality
stars and authors the lab gap makes it
easy to connect with just a press of a
button
carl padilla welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you doing
doing good
excited are you ready to talk about
entrepreneurship and leadership
yes i am
all right we're going to talk about a
subject that i that i really really am
interested in which is you know social
psychology and this is how i put it
because you're talking about audience
fans and their interaction with with
celebrities
and it's an intricate subject because
this is not a normal you know a
normal um relationship that people would
have in their daily life often me as an
audience i look at celebrities as you
know different forms of even humans
sometimes and and i'm really curious to
hear how you're leveraging technology
and your platform to bridge the gap and
to you know get a win-win situation and
so carl tell me a little bit about your
background your upbringing and what led
you to start celeb gap
um really my upbringing in my
professional career has been mostly in
sales and recruitment um you know and
that's how i
really kind of built my
you know
my revenue in order to fund this company
um but how i really kind of thought of
the idea of celeb gap is you know a
while ago i was getting married and
a friend of mine
uh who happened to be a professional
golfer uh was golfing with the uh music
producer of the guy
of who works with thomas rhett and i
happen to be dancing to thomas rhett's
song die a happy man
um so they're the record label that he
works with the guy who owns the record
label that works with thomas so he
reached out to him asked him if he could
get me something
and on my wedding day uh he handed me
the gift and it was in an envelope i
opened it up and
it was a signed
headshot of him and he said hey man i
hope you always remember your first
dance signed thomas rat
coolest gift by far out of all the gifts
that i had gotten okay so
i mean fast forward
why why was it the coolest gift that
you've got that i think that's an
important question
that's a good question so
really i think it was the coolest gift
just because the sheer fact of
the reach ability in order to get a hold
of someone like thomas rhett i mean it's
not exactly an easy feat to do
as well as you know the personalization
like we were dancing to die a happy man
from by thomas rhett
and you know the fact that he got
something so personalized
uh and meaningful for me as a gift
it it really it blew everyone else out
of the water so
you know
what to continue my story essentially
three years later you know that song
came on the radio i die a happy man and
i thought back
that that scenario of that gift that he
got me
like i got goosebumps because i was just
thinking man that was such a cool gift
if i wanted to replicate that feeling to
give to somebody else you know was there
an avenue and you know there were for
video shout outs but there wasn't really
anything to personalize signed
autographs uh directly from the
individual uh so what we wanted to do is
is really build a platform to have all
kinds of ways to connect
not only just video shout outs
personalized sign autographs but now
you're going to be able to do scheduled
video game sessions
um scheduled video calls
any kind of way that you can connect
with the individuals you know to really
bring something that at one point was a
once-in-a-lifetime experience now your
fingertips and really kind of and giving
three years of goosebumps to somebody
else so i just wanted to replicate that
same feeling so that's where we really
came up with the idea
and
doing it in an affordable way
that didn't take that much money from
the individual celebs
in order to create the in order for to
us to still be profitable and then to
also enjoy the experience
right and so strategy wise
you have to get a hold of the
celebrities as
you're creating a marketplace right so
obviously audience like me i'd love to
get an autograph signed by jerry
seinfeld oh my god but
you have to get a hold of jerry seinfeld
how how how do you go about doing that
so we so i have a big account management
team um and what they do essentially is
reach out to agencies we have
partnerships and relationships with
about 130 different agencies and
corporations
um you know that being said they're in
connection with hundreds if not
thousands of celebrities
uh so what we have done over the last
you know year is really pitch all the
agencies as well as also reaching out
individuals but we've had more success
in reaching it when it comes to root
bulk celebrities getting a large amount
of celebrities and a large amount of
reach out to reaching out to individual
agencies
which is also in built into our platform
we have an agent admin portal for all of
them to manage and monitor everything
going in and out for those individuals
um so that's where we've really been
focused uh but you know have also been
individually reaching out through their
instagram emails uh dms things like that
and scheduling calls
amazing so you mentioned to me before we
started this call that you're that
you're soon launching the next version
of the platform i love learning
experiences and i love you know learning
as an entrepreneur what you learned from
your first from your first version to
the second version
what what what what kind of things
surprised you or what did you learn
that wasn't so obvious to you that you
then decided to go and implement in the
second version
so
that's a great question uh i definitely
learned a lot uh i mean i'm i learn
every single day because you know either
something goes wrong or i have to make
sure something gets taken care of
we get better from it um we initially
built the platform for video shout outs
um and personalized sign autographs we
realized very quickly that you know it
was successful we had you know we were
doing well but it wasn't really setting
us apart from people like cameo and and
whatnot it was really just another cameo
even though we just took
we we take 19 which i believe that
they're up at 25 or 30 percent
um at this point and
um you know just
having the discounted rate wasn't enough
so what we tried to do
um
was obviously set ourselves apart from
everyone else so we tried to do add-on a
bunch of additional features
where when we initially originally did
that uh the type of code that we had
built the platform built on
uh it couldn't even would it couldn't
withstand the amount of content that it
was on it if they when i say type of
code i don't know if you come from this
kind of a background but it's almost
like a foundation if that makes sense of
a house
and we were trying to add on three or
four more floors but the foundation
couldn't handle it so we had to
rebuild the entire platform to relaunch
it to have all these additional features
you know and not only just additional
features such as video game sessions and
and video calls but people will also be
able to follow the profiles
just as you follow an instagram profile
so when they go live you know everyone
gets notified so in order to do this we
realized that the type of code
we had to go back to the drawing board
and rebuild it and in a better way
because if we're going to do this we're
going to do it right the first time
right now if you if you have to go back
in time and you know speak to yourself
as you're starting out saliva but i
think that there's an important
important lesson to be shared here for
other brother entrepreneurs that have
these great business ideas
would you what would you do differently
in in the planning or strategizing
behind the technology stack that you're
using or the development cycles or or
the people that you work with in the
technology scene
to be able to make those
small agile movements as you're learning
about what your customers and your
celebs actually want
yeah
so i mean obviously it's you know the
saying 2020 hindsight uh but uh i would
definitely take a look at if i had to go
back in time i would have made sure that
the code was you know scalable uh so
that we were able to obviously continue
to level up the platform
um
and uh
you know um
when it comes to i mean certain
marketing teams that we worked with i
probably would have done a little bit
more research
uh we spent a lot of money on marketing
out out of the gate
when
we should we should have focused that
more towards this 2.0 launch
um i don't know there's
a bunch of little things along the way
uh one thing i wish we initially did is
that we
you know we we originally had a
headquarters and then covet came out
and
you know
to be honest i i wish we all are had
everything set up for at home uh work
from home at that time
um but you know we had to learn a lot
for that kind of a situation um right
i mean
i don't know there's a lot of things
that we learned over the last year that
has really made it to so that this
rollout
uh is going to be a lot better
is this vision for celeb gap was it
always clear amongst your team members
is this something that you had to work
hard to
to share with them or or was it pretty
clear where all of you guys are heading
in this ship
so every
i would say the majority of my team
members have really been on board and
excited about this entire thing they
feel like they're a part of a family um
you know they they really get excited
about uh really the job in general is
really fun uh for especially for an
account manager on my team i mean yeah
think about it you're really associating
with really big agencies you know like
in setting up calls with roc nation you
know full screen having conversations
with the wwe you know and and and you
know the mlb and things like that
um so everyone
my team has supported the growth we
they've supported the time that we've
had to take out to take off to rebuild
because
any kind of competitive edge just gives
them more of a competitive edge to sell
the platform to individual agencies and
celebs
um right so i don't know if that answers
that your question no no definitely
definitely how do you learn
about what people want on your platform
so you launch the platform you're going
to launch 2.0
and you're going to see a bunch of data
and a bunch of engagement and a bunch of
different weird things
what what kind of process do you as a
leader put together
to sort of either hold yourself
accountable for whether you're going on
the right track
or or whether you've been asking the
right questions on what you should be
working on
um
so we've always been open to you know
different you know suggestions
um and i think that you know change is
inevitable and that's you know something
you have to work with especially when it
comes to catering to the needs you know
when we originally launched we didn't
have an agent admin portal for all the
agencies that's something that we built
you know some people said they they
weren't into the video shout outs but if
they had roc nation told us if if we had
video games you know that would be way
more of an interest for them if tell me
a little bit about this video game idea
because that that that that sounds so
crazy to me what is this video game
feature
so you're going to be able to schedule
video game sessions with celebs um so
they're going to lay out the times that
they're going to be available
uh and you're going to be able to
purchase them and they're going to send
you the invite at the time you join the
lobby and whatever time frame whether it
be 20 30 an hour that they're going to
set aside for the time and then whatever
price that they deem that it would be
worth it for them uh that's what they're
going to set it up for and then
individuals are going to be purchasing
it and
and then you know let's just say for
that week that's their schedule's done
everyone's purchased up the schedule and
then they in two weeks
they renew it and they put out a new
schedule and they put themselves active
every single person that follows them is
going to be notified that they have a
new schedule of willing to game
and uh people can purchase
um so
just to be clear you're literally
playing you're playing video games with
the celebs
correct so you could you could i mean
and and you don't have to it isn't
something where it's like a twitch
platform where it's going to be
streaming we're simply bridging the gap
and facilitating the scheduling uh for
the individuals in order to connect you
know whereas before you couldn't just
reach out to one of these individuals
and be like hey man would you like to
game
uh that that's something that doesn't
happen uh whereas we give them the
ability to do that um now they can
stream if they would like on twitch or
facebook or whatever platform or youtube
that they want but it's not a
requirement it's really i just find it
fascinating that this is a core feature
that you're talking about you know and
obviously you know it's a changing
generation and there's different you
know the the way that the world works
i'm not a gamer myself but you know when
i think of what are the top few things
that i would want to
you know the way that i would want to
engage with it with a celebrity of some
sort
style you know my jury seinfeld you know
gaming you know i it now it makes sense
now when i when i think about it more
critically but you know to me it sounds
like it's sort of a i'm i may have an
older generation inside of me for that
yeah well i mean it's more of an
immersive hanging out that right right
yeah you know rather than a video shout
out which is just something that they
get they're not talking back and forth
the individual's just
talking into a camera and whether it's
wishing happy birthday or whatever the
case may be
um and whereas this you're literally
conversating back and forth and hanging
out with you know your favorite
celebrity or whoever it may be or you
know or even just a gaming streamer that
you follow i mean whoever decides to be
on the platform
why did you decide to be an entrepreneur
why why go on this crazy journey ups and
downs difficulties happy moments why
i would definitely it's
it's probably one of the toughest things
that i've ever embarked on uh
you know
you see these individuals that are crazy
successful and you realize that you know
they're not like bionic beings you know
and or
or have any kind of special powers and
they're living incredible lives and
they're successful and
and so
i don't know i it's something that i i
wanted to embark on and also be one of
those individuals
um
and also
i i
i thought it was i i've truly wanted to
bring the same feeling that i got
from
[Music]
that experience to other individuals
you know
as i mentioned you can't just reach out
to someone and say hey man would you
like to game you know that that doesn't
happen
um you know so being able to bring that
experience to people you know whether it
be for gifts themselves or whatever it
that would bring me joy to see something
like that come to life
um so something that you created
uh and people that supported it and
people that are a part of it you know
it's just it's a different kind of
feeling
uh right then obviously you know working
for somebody
do you think that you would still be an
entrepreneur if you didn't have that
magical experience of receiving this
gift that opened your eyes and gave you
this aha moment so in other words i'm
asking is entrepreneurship a you know an
innate part of you or is this something
that you now feel that you're forced to
do or or not a force but you're
empowered to do because you've you've
had an aha moment that that you know now
you cannot you know sleep at night until
you enable
ins in a in a scalable way many others
to have that same magical experience
that you've had
so you said
do you think i would still do it
if you would still be an entrepreneur in
another venture or whether this
entrepreneurship was almost forced on
you because you have to now solve this
problem
that you've that you've discovered
yourself
i i think i i
i mean it's a very unique idea that i've
embarked on um
i don't know if i would go into the tech
industry again
um
if i was to embark on another venture
i i because the tech industry is
definitely it's a difficult one um yeah
you know
obviously you know coding and you know
errors that pop up and and things like
that uh but i i still think would say
that i've enjoyed this experience
it's you know brought a lot of joy to me
as well as my team and other individuals
um so i i would say yeah i would i would
i would jump into it but i don't know if
i would go back into the tech industry
i love it now i usually ask people where
where they gather their inspiration from
in their day to day abandoned but i
think this whole conversation was about
you know
where you've gathered your inspiration
from and where sort of your vision lies
but take me back a little bit in time a
lot in time you know middle school
elementary school
what really fascinates you as a kid you
know where's your head at what you know
as you go about middle school what what
kind of things excite you or or interest
you
i i gotta be honest i mean
i i didn't i was i didn't become
ambitious really at all until
i don't know
end of college
so like in middle school like i that
didn't even come to my head like i
wasn't even thinking about what i was
going to do or if i was going to be a
business owner or
anything like that i mean i think life
changes
how you know help you make decisions and
you know things that happen to you or
how well you do in certain things that
you know pique your interest in others i
so like when it comes to middle school i
was just working you know thinking about
sports
video games with kids i i wouldn't say i
was you know thinking about being a
business owner back then
got it and if i would ask
different people around you whether it's
your your colleagues your your your
employees the different you know
celebrities what what are some words
that they would describe
carl what what were they saying
um
driven
self-made loyal
um
empathetic uh
courageous
i would say the most mostly would be
driven confident
very very cool
carl i really want to thank you for the
time uh i love hearing different
journeys and i love hearing different
entrepreneurial journeys and especially
those that you know come up because of
you know those personal moments and and
i wish you best of luck with it with a
new launch of of the next version of
celeb gap and trying it out myself and i
like i said i think it's a fascinating
world
bridging you know these two worlds you
know the audience and fans and the
celebrities and and the whole social
interaction that is now being made
possible because of technology i think
it's just fascinating so thank you very
much best of luck and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you you too appreciate the time
thank you